[Music]
everybody else
sucks too let me let me tell you about
this dude tell that dude to come and see
me
because i'm gonna [ __ ] destroy his
[ __ ] insecurity he's a piece of [ __ ]
for doing that you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
hey gary what's good bro i'm so excited
right now
it's good to have you here what's your
name uh i king i king
great name so my question is about
linkedin
okay i'll give you a little bit of
context real quick before i go into that
question please um
so um so my background is my stepfather
he
was so he pulled me and my siblings out
of school we were really young like four
and five years old
he basically put this fear in the in us
that the
everyone in the world was trying to kill
us that um
he's the only person that can protect us
like he's our guardian angel
he didn't let us go outside alone um our
lives
ran like that huh it was some dark [ __ ]
yeah some really really dark stuff and
our lives ran like that until
about like i was 22 um
yeah thank you um so 22 comes
you know please come in arrest him
whatever
um then life begins you know and this is
you know four years later you know
you kind of got to grow up really fast
18 years lost and
you know no social interaction i lost by
king this is important
perspective tweaks not lost you know not
lost
like in a lot of ways you've gained
strengths that none of us will ever
understand
in a lot of ways you've been given
insecurities and fears that none of us
will
understand but just like sean earlier
with tourette's like
this is where people really make a huge
mistake in my opinion
they don't realize that their uniqueness
is a strength i
working my through my entire adults
adolescence gave me incredible strengths
that everybody can see
it also created shortcomings with
certain parts of my relationship craft
because
i didn't mature in areas that everybody
else did you know
for and so like i think it's important
to understand that
that i just want to make sure that you
don't fully go into the place
that so many have gone into which will
lead to unhappiness through your 80s
little in your 20s
not lost just a different path
okay and some unique strengths that
maybe we haven't unders
haven't discovered or uncovered yet some
unique strengths my man
yeah thank you keep going um so yeah so
give my you know get my ged go do a
vacation at school get a job doing that
for three years as a medical assistant
you didn't go to school you were
homeschooled
home schooled technically but no real
course material or
just kept in the house basically like
jailed in the house
keep the cage yeah pretty much and how
like like some of the [ __ ] that you see
in the documentaries right like that one
documentary those boys like like that
kind of stuff right
yeah so what the outside world for you
was tv and did you even have tv and
internet did he like cut that off that
was
that was it was only antenna um tv
cable was cut off and then that was
extremely regulated
so the only television was like sesame
street stuff like that even as we grew
up into
you know our adolescent years yeah um
intense [ __ ] man i have a lot of empathy
for you keep going
so um gee i got my ged driver's license
tried to adapt
um was medical assistant for three years
kind of got bored with that
um then i decided you know i'm from i
was originally from south jersey
yeah atlanta i grew up atlantic city
love it inside there yeah so
um i just i have family here in florida
they have some great hearts they're like
come down here if you ever you know
want to you know change of pace and
stuff like that so i'm down here with
them right now
um i got into health insurance selling
health insurance little did i know the
like the arm season for that pass so i
came in the off season
and coveted hit so definitely slowed
things down
i'm i'm working you know part-time job
getting a full-time job and then
at the same time trying to work on my
health insurance
because i know when open enrollment
comes around it's going to be great
now my question is i i'm
created a linkedin profile of course um
so i can try and get into the
professional
world a little bit and one gentleman
that had connected with
he was like i'm very careful of who i
let into my into my networks
i'm already different that's already a
very bad statement
okay keep going um yeah he was like
um i'm very careful who i let into my
network and
um what else do you have to offer me to
me besides health insurance what out of
value can you bring to me
and it kind of hit me at a little bit
it really stopped me for a little bit
that day and i was like
i don't really have any other value i
went to his profile he had
a couple of different companies he
worked for different positions he held
uh if he went to a couple like got a
couple college degrees and i'm like
so that was a kind of bit of my length
my question about linkedin
i feel like i get intimidated with that
everybody else
sucks too let me let me tell you about
this dude tell that dude to come and see
me
because i'm gonna [ __ ] destroy his
[ __ ] insecurity he's a piece of [ __ ]
for doing that okay
okay give a [ __ ] what degrees he had or
where he worked [ __ ] that dude
it's not better than me [ __ ] him
okay the you know
what you know that's tapping into the
[ __ ]
insecurity of uh that [ __ ] i want to
punch that [ __ ] dude in the face
yeah don't let somebody don't like
listen you grew up in
first of all the level of strength that
you have is like [ __ ]
earth shattering i can do do you
actually understand
the fact that you're this functional
like
speaks to like an incredible like you've
i promise you
i don't know that guy i've know you for
four minutes
on with every ounce of my soul
i know that you're 17 trillion times
stronger than that dude
he has created an insecure framework
and you have flourished
out of garbage with pure strength
i mean that or do you think i'm wrong
like when you hear that or you're like
yeah gary
were you like what do you mean or are
you like nah
i tend to always put myself on the back
burner you know because that's the way i
was raised
like that's like my stepfather would be
like you're here to sir you know the
only reason you're around is to serve me
and to help me and my priorities is what
comes first
but you know you know that and you you
consciously
obviously it's your framework but you
know that's not true right
i know it's not true what you have to be
careful to is you're going to gravitate
towards it
yeah they're a partner in life whether
that business scenario my fear for you
is you're going to go towards that kind
of situation
yeah and i'm working i'm i'm working
hard
to consciously try and recorrect that
i can tell which is why it's so [ __ ]
awesome
no thank you you know most people don't
even realize they're doing it most
people don't realize they're going into
abusive relationships
because that was the framework they
don't even see it they don't have the
tweak
you have you're so woke for such a
young man and just so freshly out of
that cocoon
it's it's actually incredibly inspiring
to me
yeah thank you you're actually a
blessing you know what you've done for
me on this show
you've made all the [ __ ] tens of
thousands of other people that are
watching this right now
take a step back and stop complaining
about that they aren't going to the gym
as often as they used to
like you've put things in perspective
for thousands of people right now
who cry about what they had or their
their parent didn't do this or they
didn't buy me a new car
or they you know like you just [ __ ]
like pierced people through the [ __ ]
soul
yeah i think
yeah i think the tactical question about
linkedin is garbage the bigger question
is
you dude you're strong
like i king's a good name for you
you you kind of know you're strong right
i
i do see it sometimes um there and i
acknowledge it and then there are the
times of course you know you can't
always acknowledge it
and and and be at yours you have
siblings that were in that i do yeah
three three sisters and and of course
i'm sure they've
they've him some of them are handling it
differently than you have right
yeah we're all remarkably strong i would
say
we're not we're not all like knit tight
like that
um but we yes we are processing it
differently yeah
and some need you know like that would
make sense to me like
i even am sitting and trying to put
myself in that scenario i might go off
and just be like yo i'm going to be like
with me for a minute you know like that
would make sense to me
that's really good dna thank god for
that
yeah sure um so
so i shouldn't let that bother me if i'm
trying to put content out on linkedin
whether you know people want to crush my
credentials or anything like that
hi king the fact that you showed up in
the episode that we established the
hashtag
everybody else sucks too is the greatest
[ __ ] thing of all time
of course you shouldn't let it bother
them remember this there's only a very
small group of people on linkedin
that are on paper or in theory more
successful than me
i'm telling you right to your [ __ ]
face as a human that you're a [ __ ]
man
so if you're gonna take other people's
validations there's only about
a small group left on linkedin that can
trump
me you know in that status what have you
so good news you can tell the other 99
percent to go [ __ ] themselves
there you go there's a little gift i'm
telling your face that you're the
[ __ ] guy
that i want to be friends with you that
i'm like sitting here like should i hire
this dude like
i'm about you so if you're in a
framework where you take other people's
opinions as value which by the way i
don't think you should
[ __ ] my opinion above you or not people
but
if you're in that place because we all
go through it
next week when you feel it be like [ __ ]
this person garyvee said i'm the best
and they suck compared to garyvee
if that's what you want my thing is i
want you to get real
quiet talk about cutting out you know
you unfortunately
took you know you know it's so crazy
it's so emotional how i just got when
you just said yes sir because i'm just
like
imagining your [ __ ] life and it just
[ __ ] makes me want to
rip that [ __ ] person apart
on the flip side i'm so grateful that
you have the dna of this level of
strength that would have broke
so many people now bro you're good
you're real good
like when you're you're most down please
go back and watch this clip
hear those words hear them from somebody
that [ __ ] knows [ __ ]
i have intuit i was blessed with [ __ ]
intuition juices that
be illegal one day like you're good bro
you're [ __ ] good
[ __ ] that dude the [ __ ] audacity he
doesn't let people into his [ __ ]
linkedin
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] loser
he's just a junior version of the
[ __ ] evil your stepdad tried to do
yeah
scared people do scared things
that's true i feel bad for those two
i know that's something i've been
hearing you say and it's really changed
my perspective a lot instead of being
angry
probably having some empathy for them
100 they're broke as [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] broken we're not broken
and you you got time too you got your
whole [ __ ] life
i was feeling like i was behind because
i heard you but when you were like oh
when i left my dad's wine store at 30
something
and i built you know vaynermedia [ __ ] i
mean carl sanders made a kentucky fried
chicken happen in his [ __ ] 60s or 70s
yeah you're awake off at 40.
are you kidding me [ __ ] me i'm like one
tiny example
there's only and by the way back to
success how about the 63 year old that
[ __ ] finally went to therapy
and got happy how about the 59 year old
that finally figured out actually my
mom's a piece of
[ __ ] so [ __ ] her i'm not living for her
validation anymore i'm going to live
like this and at 64
got happy for 20 years and lived life
instead of when 84 always [ __ ] up in
that scenario
[ __ ] me there's millions out there doing
it yeah
can i ask one more one more thing yeah
so i was listening to one of your 4ds um
yesterday when i was at work
um and you had mentioned something that
you can
you can't grow your chest you can't
build a chest and that's something that
you never would be able to do because
it's not your body type
actually bro honestly it started
starting to come out it started
you know what's funny though when you
have no chest muscle
i was like going at it for like two
years i'm like oh and of course i kind
of knew because you see those thin
boxers they don't the biggest chess but
like i
i logically knew i was being a little
bit more tongue-in-cheek
but i'll tell you this you [ __ ] need
that foundation like now
it's growing exponentially because i can
actually feel it because i have one so
the
so my form is better because you know
jordan was like i was doing this one
thing he's like feel it i'm like what
the [ __ ] he talking about
yeah how can you think i don't know am i
like doing it right like so anyway
i was a little tongue-in-cheek with it
yeah so my question was um
i don't know why this got weird maybe it
was the way i said it this man is not 40
years old
he's 22 what are you 22 you said 26. 26.
which he looks great for 26 but
nonetheless keep going yeah so um
on my instagram i'm like fitness and
health um inclined
so and lately what i've been doing is
like tutorials on different exercises
and stuff like that would it
i would i wanted to put up some chest
specific tutorials
you and
and i was hoping you can follow me at
that point i just don't want to ask for
a follow-up
about something i appreciate you not
asking for the follow
up but you've earned it with your
incredible
humanity here rise body i
highly expect and
desperately ask that this man's 409
becomes 4009
in the next 30 minutes boom
solid i started 296 today i know you say
don't
not follow followers and likes but
listen no
don't let that be your affirmation but
yeah bro i like your chest i see it
good [ __ ] okay listen to me
you're a [ __ ] blessing you can really
help a lot of people by the way
i would mix in some of your real life
story into your content
you can help a lot of kids yeah i'm
working on it
good i appreciate you gary thank you you
got a king
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from feel free to
check it out